shae's in houston hi shea welcome to the
ramsay show
hello um can y'all hear me sure what's
up
okay hey dave so glad to finally meet
you um
so my question is i'm 30 years old i
started your plan
in 2017 single mother of two kids
by trade i'm an rn and so in 2020
i went to zellington took advantage of
the kovit thing
quit working full-time started travel
nursing
so my income went from 85
to almost 300 000 last year
i grew up i grew up super i grew up
super
freaking poor like and it's just me and
my boys you know left the toxic
family environment yadda yadda so
anyways
i have been hoarding money because i was
scared
that crap you know like if i pay this
off my credit score is going to go down
so
basically i started out with almost 83
000 worth of debt
and i have 42 000 left and it's only
student loans left to pay
well when i paid my car off my credit
score
went down i kind of i kind of skipped
i'm not really skipped but i've got the
three to six months obviously saved
but i'm so you're doing your plan
because you're working your plan
and well you can't modify my plan and
call it my plan it's your plan
okay you're sitting in a situation where
the doctor tells the patient
do these three things the patient goes
i'm gonna do two of them
and they come back two weeks later and
that infection is now the size of a
softball and you're like what did you do
and you're like well i only did two of
the three take that dumb medicine
really really quick though i've got 56
000
in my savings yeah so i was like really
quick how much debt have you got
forty two thousand dollars left so
you're debt-free about the time we get
off the phone call what's the problem
i'm i know but i'm scared i won't be
able to get me and my boys a house
why no without without you oh you mean
without a credit score
yes okay well just make sure all of your
accounts are closed
and all of them have a zero balance so
that you actually do have a credit score
not just a low credit score
okay because there's only two ways you
can get a house a high credit
score or no credit score you can't get
it with a low credit score
okay so you want to make sure you have
nothing to do nothing open
everything needs to be closed and zero
balance
no outstanding bad debt so that it does
because if you go to a mortgage company
like churchill mortgage
and you say i have a zero credit score
they can walk through what a process
called manual underwriting and get you a
house the same exact price as you would
have gotten
if you had a 746 credit score okay
okay they can do that okay but you
can't do it with a 576.
because that's where i'm at right now
because everything's paid off but it's
just
like my credit cards are just you know
they're opening there but
they're still open yeah close them yeah
and zero balance
everything and six months later you'll
have a zero score
okay i'm gonna do it i'm gonna pull up
your credit bureau report pull up your
credit bureau report and anything that's
on there
make sure that account is zeroed and
closed by friday
hey listen to me listen two things
number one
at the end of at end of business today
you are
free you got it i want you to
hear that word in your soul i'm not
gonna hoard it i'm gonna i'm gonna do it
hey here's the second thing yeah you are
not what happened to you as a kid
you are creating a new legacy for those
boys their story is not gonna be your
story you're a freaking three hundred
thousand
dollars you're a rock star
you are h town's finest you've done it
you turned the corner on them
don't get held back by those old stories
that are going to continue to
try to weasel their way into your heart
they're dead and listen if somebody says
if somebody says you forgot your raisin
yup let's go i don't eat raisins
well i'm so glad i freaking met you and
i want to finish out to my friend mitch
because he's the one who told me to call
well we're so glad for nick and so glad
for you yeah